the demigods are each and all the direct
offspring of queen america there was
godwin morgot
moog radan
reichardt rani mikhala and melania blade
of mykla melania blade of mickeleh
melania blade of mykola and millenia
not again all of these demigods had
fallen from grace by the time the
shattering occurred but in this video i
want to mostly talk about the origins of
these characters who these demigods were
before the fall
and some of these demigods fell a long
way indeed
before he became this unsightly mess
godwin the golden was quite the heroic
figure he was born of the promising
union between lord godfrey and queen
america and he achieved great renown for
his bravery in one of their wars at
least
the war of the ancient dragons this war
began when grand sax a great ancient
dragon reigned calamity down upon lane
dell marking the only time in historical
record that landel's walls had fallen
it's not clear why grand sacks first
attacked but fortifying themselves
against lightning the knights of the odd
tree weathered his assault and
grandstacks was defeated however this
was only the beginning and a bitter war
against the ancient dragons was to
follow
during this war the ur tree sentinels
had an epiphany that the only way to
truly protect the old tree was to become
dragons themselves
and so despoiling the corpses of their
foes the grotesque sentinels served the
odd tree but fought with the claws of
the enemy instead in the end the ancient
dragons were routed once again in a
graveyard of swords by the stormcaller
church the end of the war is
commemorated
here we learned that during battle
godwin the golden defeated fortesacs
called the mightiest dragon of them all
however he did not kill fortesacs
instead he befriended him and it was in
this act that the powers of the ancient
dragons truly became a part of lane dell
after all only those loved by dragons
can survive the ordeal of cladding their
bodies in lightning so from an unlikely
friendship an ancient dragon cult was
born in the capital city and the knights
of lane dale learned to worship the
dragons and wield their lightning
lanciax sister of fortesacs even took
human form to better commune with the
knights it was officially decided that
the worship of the ancient dragons did
not conflict with belief in the old tree
and it was all thanks to godwin
commander of the dragon's golden
lightning and a true child of the golden
lineage
but now let's talk about morgot and moog
the omen twins who were also born of
godfrey and america's golden lineage
first what is an omen well to put it
simply an omen is an accursed child seen
as impure as they are born with horns on
the body and face when this happens the
correct thing to do culturally at least
is to cut off the horns of the omen an
act which usually causes them to perish
it's pretty messed up
but some omen do survive this process
and some omen are even given a cleaver
crafted specifically for them and
awarded as a tool of war although these
weapons are bestowed with a readiness to
take them away
we find one such omen in an urgery camp
upon the altus plateau before you fight
it you might have noticed another omen
nearby writhing in its sleep it's said
that omens see evil spirits in their
nightmares and i think this omen is
dreaming haunted by the vengeful spirits
of its accursed kin
this brings us to the omen killers who
are horrifying butchers of twisted
conscience they wear these horned masks
that make a mockery of the omens
nightmares and these butchers hunt the
omen and amputate their horns the first
german killer was named rolo a famous
perfumer who had to imbibe a physic to
rid himself of emotion so that he could
better perform his tasks
remember it seems many omen have their
horns excised when they're very young
that's definitely disturbing enough to
warrant an emotion killing physic in my
book
however if the omen is born of royalty
then their horns are not cut off but the
omen is kept underground unbeknownst to
anyone and imprisoned for eternity by
way of example you would have seen all
kinds of omen confined to the sewers
beneath lane dell but why are omen
considered to be accursed in the first
place some of them are clearly
intelligent so what's inherently wrong
with being born with horns and great
strength
well it's important to remember i think
that this curse might only really exist
in the context of the golden order after
all those afflicted with omen horns are
not able to return to the old tree for
rebirth and are said to be born outside
of its grace
but why does the golden order disavow
the omen then well it's hard to say for
sure but my working theory is that it's
to do with the crucible
according to this ancient incantation
horns were once an aspect of the erd
tree's primordial crucible where all
life was once blended together and with
the exception of a couple of crucible
nights in and around lane dell we know
that the golden order has started to
distance itself from most things that
touch upon the crucible while things
like horns knots feathers and scales
once grew on the human body and were
considered signifiers of the divine
now they are disdained as impurities as
civilization has advanced we learn this
from the knot scale and feather
talismans all of which are guarded by
omen or dropped by omen killers no less
unfortunately for the order of the earth
tree these once divine impurities seem
to crop up in some births whether they
like it or not almost like it's a
genetic trait as if it touches upon the
crucible at the root of the earth tree
and so you have to ask is it really a
curse to be born as a graceless omen
well as with most curses in these games
i think that depends on your perspective
in any case moog and morgot were omen
royalty and thus they were born into a
wretched mire far below the earth horns
and all here they were kept under the
strictest confinement each of them were
bound with charmed shackles that were
covered in roots or thorns and bathed in
golden magic
it seems very few people were supposed
to know that they even existed
morgot for his part renounced and
despised his accursed omen blood but his
brother moog embraced it deep
underground moog stood before an outer
god a being called the formless mother
who craves wounds a being capable of
bestowing power upon her cursed blood in
this moment moog's accursed blood
erupted with fire and he became besotted
with the defilement that he was born
into here deep below the earth he would
go on to build a dynasty of blood in
reverence of a mother something it seems
he never truly had
as for morgoth he was born into the same
accursed fate as his twin brother but
despite not being blessed with grace he
loved the odd tree all the same and even
took it upon himself to crawl out of the
sewers and become the urban tree's
protector when the odd tree needed him
most
in the end he rightfully became the omen
king and lord of landel omen or not he
was after all born of godfrey and
america's golden lineage
of course the marriage between godfrey
and america would be ended and before
long america remarried with another man
a champion named ratigan who america
calls her other half
he became second eldon lord and the king
consort but he also brought with him
three children from a previous marriage
that he had had with a carrion queen
named ranala these children were rani
reichard and radan and they all became
demigod's stepchildren after ratigan's
union reunion with queen america
possessed of his father's flaming red
hair radan was fond of its heroic
implications and considered himself to
be born of a great champion yet he also
looked up to another man godfrey the
first elden lord queen america's first
husband and the lord of the battlefield
but radhan wasn't just the son of
ratigan and an aspiring lord of the
battlefield he was also the son of
ranala who was head of the academy of
raya lukaria and queen of caria so as a
carrion royal inclined towards sorcery
radan bent his will towards mastering
gravitational magics rock sling gravity
well collapsing stars these techniques
were taught to him in celia the town of
sorcery all so he would never have to
abandon his beloved but scrawny steed
that said before long his powers would
be put towards a more cosmic purpose
than simply allowing him to ride his own
horse
radan was taught gravitational magic by
an alabaster lord a member of a race of
ancients with skin of stone who was said
to have risen to life when a meteor
struck long ago and when his lessons
were complete pradhan uttered these
chilling words thank you for your
tutelage for now i can challenge the
stars
and of course he did conquer the stars
and the very constellations would be
halted by his strength but of course you
kind of have to ask why why was it
necessary to conquer the stars in the
first place well i have a couple of
theories theory one is that it was done
in self-defense
after all according to the sword
gravestone radan was protecting celia
what's more gravitational magic has
destructive power and many gravitational
beasts are proof of that destructive
power a being named astel had even come
down to the lands between in the past
and destroyed a place called the eternal
city what's more seliens are descendants
of the eternal positioned right above
the eternal city underground so there is
an argument to be made for radhan purely
defending celia for some reason here
but it's possible for radhan to have
fought in this conflict and to have made
the first move as well so this is theory
two that redan conquered the stars as a
preventative measure in service to the
greater will
according to a set of astrologer items
the night sky cradles fate
there's even a banished sect of people
called the knox who live deep below the
earth in eternal anticipation of the
coming age of stars and their lord of
night
long ago these people invoked the ire of
the greater will
so it would make sense that those in
service to the greater will might have
sought to arrest the stars and put an
end to this fate what's more radhan was
just a huge fanboy of godfrey and he
seems to have more loyalty to the old
tree than to the moon
finally the telescope item description
says that the fate once writ in the
night skies had been fettered by the
golden order so surely this is
referencing radan's actions and it
levels the blame at the golden order but
putting radhan's motivations aside it's
a fact that the stars were held back and
that this had great consequences for
many especially for the rest of his
carrion royal family let me explain
the fate of the karyan royal family is
guided by the stars
as is the fate of lady rani
first air in the karyan royal line
but general radha is the conqueror of
the stars who stood up to the swirling
constellations halting their movement in
a smashing victory
and so if general radan were defeated
the stars would once again resume their
movement
as would lady rani's destiny
luna princess rani was the daughter of
radigan and ranala and sister to redan
interestingly if you look at her true
body atop the divine tower it looks like
she might have also inherited the red
hair of ratigan
cool detail but unlike her brother radan
she quite clearly took after her mother
moore who was rinala head of the carrion
royal family
the house of caria has this storied
history one that seems to go way back to
the astrologers in the carrion manor we
find one of their treasures the sword of
night and flame
it reads astrologers who preceded the
sorcerers established themselves in
mountain tops that nearly touched the
sky and considered the fire giants their
neighbours rinala herself was an
astrologer always chasing the stars in
her youth then she met the full moon and
in time the astrologer became a queen
establishing the house of karya as
royalty
carrier appears to have a matriarchal
hierarchy with multiple princesses and
carrier knights that serve as their
retainers
now however there is only one princess
rani daughter of ronaldo and at the time
of her birth she would have been set to
inherit quite a lot of power indeed for
the carrion royal family was at its
height and her mother was not only queen
she was also head of the academy of raya
lukaria having bewitched them with the
enchanting power of the full moon
leading the young rani by the hand
rinala guided her daughter to a meeting
with a moon of her own what rani beheld
was cold dark and veiled in occult
mystery a dark moon a sort of twin to
ranala's own full moon you can even see
both of these hanging in the sky if you
stargaze from the heights of the
moonlight plateau another who guided
rani was a character called the snowy
crone who the young rani encountered
deep in the woods when you look at rani
it's actually the likeness of this snow
witch that you're seeing as the doll
that now houses rani's soul was modeled
after her probably as a sign of respect
clearly rani looked up to this
mysterious woman she became rani's
secret mentor and she even knew about
the dark moon teaching the young rani to
fear it as she imparted her cold
sorceries
so what do these moons represent that's
just a theory but i think the moons kind
of act as guides
the lost black moon of noxtella for
example was the guide of countless stars
what's more rani and ranala were heavily
influenced by their moons rinala's moon
bewitched the academy that she became
the head of and rani's darkmoon for its
part also imparts wisdom and leads a
voyage in the age of stars ending they
could even be outer gods
and yet for all of this guidance carrier
and leonia as a whole have experienced
steep decline ratigan betrayed the house
of the moon radan locked the stars out
of motion the academy town is flooded to
the north carrier has been ruined in the
west and the stars and moon have gone
their separate ways
nevertheless rani last princess of karya
remains
carefully setting new plans into motion
sibling to rani and radhan was a man
named reichard who was lord of the
volcano manor there is evidence that
reichard was friendly with his siblings
he conspired with his sister rani later
on and there's even a portrait of
vradaan hung in the volcano manor as
well as a portrait of reichardt himself
before the fall
item descriptions mark reichard as stern
ambitious heroic and blasphemous
a part of this blasphemy was opposing
the odd tree which actually drew many
nights to his banner for reichard
believed in taking by force just as the
gods did and clearly many believe that
he would usher in a new age
the armor set of the galmia knights
reveals to us what were once very loyal
soldiers the crest of red feathers are
there to symbolize reichard's pedigree
as lord radigan's son
and the emblem upon their chest piece
represents a lord who had lofty
ambitions
however as reichard delved into the
ancient secrets of mount gelmir he came
across the immortal great serpent an
ancient deity that aligned with
reichard's ambitions and so reichhardt
fed himself to the great serpent so that
he might devour grow and live eternally
alas this was too much for his knights
and they believed that their masters
heroic ambitions had degenerated into
mere greed
so they searched desperately for a
weapon with which they might halt their
lord and they found it too the immortal
serpent had lived for a long time and so
there was also a weapon to kill it that
had been designed long ago as well a
serpent hunter
but it was too late as the lord lost his
dignity so too did the knights lose
their master not that it bothered
reichardt
next we need to discuss melania and
mikala these two were twins as they were
born
no reichard please anyway as you know
radigan's marriage with ranala did not
last afterwards he returned to the
golden order and became queen america's
consort but what i haven't yet mentioned
is that together they were blessed with
two demigod children the so-called twin
prodigies
now in the last lore video i briefly
proposed that these two twins were born
after the shattering after ratigan and
america had merged together to become a
single god however i've since changed my
mind i think millennia and michela were
clearly born before the shattering
there's just so much proof that these
two twins were a force that were
influencing the world long before the
shattering took place
anyway both of these twins were born
afflicted specifically in the japanese
text it's said that their births were
vulnerable mykola was born afflicted
with eternal youth and millennia for her
part was vulnerable to rot
interestingly melania's scarlet rot is
actually an outer god
this outer god like many others in the
game seems to have an order that is able
to be imposed upon the world via an
imperial vessel
and millennia was that vessel and while
the scarlet rot is pretty terrible you
can sort of argue that it's got a beauty
to it
according to gary the order of rot is
resplendent it's a cycle of death and
rebirth
kind of like the lotus flower which is a
flower that blooms a new beautiful and
fresh from mud
i actually have art of this flower
hanging in my home i always love the
symbol of it i actually have lots of art
hanging now and i'm going to talk about
all of this artwork that you can buy at
the end of the video anyway so millennia
the empyrean was vulnerable too and
afflicted by the scarlet rot there was
said to be no cure to this and while
fire and consecration seem to be
somewhat effective at warding it off
millennia would slowly lose her physical
self to the rot
interestingly old legends of the scarlet
rot have persisted in the world for
generations and we learn more about the
rot god from the blue dancer charm
the dancer in blue represents a fairy
who in legend bestowed a flowing sword
upon a blind swordsman blade in hand the
swordsman sealed away an ancient god a
god that was rot itself
specifically this god was long ago
sealed away in the stagnant water that
is downstream of the ainsle river
underground and wherever rot appears the
kindred of rot appear as well these are
pests and servants of the rod and now in
the current age these are servants that
have been forsaken by millennia who is
their new goddess so this blind
swordsman with the flowing curved sword
actually went on to become millennia's
mentor so technically it's him that we
have to blame for this goddamn attack
the prosthesis wearer heirloom tells us
more a talisman engraved with a scene
from a heroic tale though born into the
accursed rot when the young girl
encountered her mentor and his flowing
blade she gained wings of unparalleled
strength millennia's ridiculous attack
is called the waterfowl dance and
aesthetically it makes sense that you
know flowing waters would counter the
effects of rot
for just as still waters turn foul
stagnation turns to decay
thus warriors must remain ever drifting
and indeed millennia does resist the
call of the rot there's a lot of
evidence that she's not really a willing
vessel but through sheer will and sense
of self she resists the roth and only
when she is truly pressed in battle will
she abandon this will and bloom into the
goddess within
millennia's first bloom was during her
fight against radhan and releasing her
scarlet roth was a last-ditch effort
that would forever taint the land of
khalid and [ __ ] radhan so whatever
she was fighting for in this fight
against pradhan somehow it was worth
this terrible act
in general terms at least it's clear
that millennia was fighting for her
brother apart from the times where she
relapses into being the goddess of rot
she is known as the blade of mykla she
actually goes to great lengths to tell
you this i don't know if you heard
despite being the toughest boss in from
software history she's actually fighting
for his right to godhood not her own in
millennia's own words her brother mikala
possesses the wisdom the allure of a god
he is the most fearsome emperian of all
for his part mikala did a lot to earn
his sister's dedication not the least of
which was inspiring her armor and a
prosthetic of unalloyed gold
and it's not just his sister that loved
mykola many people did
the bewitching branch is an item that
you can use to turn enemies into
temporary allies and it reads indeed he
has learned very well how to compel such
affection
for his father radigan mykola fashioned
and gifted to him a fundamentalist
incantation called triple rings of light
radigan then returns the favor gifting
back an incantation
called ratigan's rings of light these
interactions show some of mykola's
positive connections with his father and
also golden order fundamentalism
and yet the young mykola abandoned
fundamentalism for it could do nothing
to treat millennia's accursed rot
this was the beginning of unalloyed gold
so what is unalloyed gold
well an alloy is a composition of metals
so
unalloyed gold is pure gold essentially
with no external mixtures
this gold apparently can ward away the
meddling of outer gods and so mikala
bent a lot of his efforts towards
creating an unalloyed gold needle
specifically this needle was crafted for
his sister to ward off the rot god and
forced all the effects of the incurable
rotting sickness
we see the bond between the siblings as
well when we visit nicholas haleg tree
we see a statue of a one-armed woman
embracing a child mikula
in this place we see the biggest example
of myklas benevolence the helic tree and
the society that was built into the
brace that supports it this was a
promised land seen as a salvation to
many who were shunned or persecuted
provided that they can actually find the
path here of course
and like many other empirians michela
seems to have had the will within them
to create a new order and his is an
order that's somewhat modelled on the
ones that came before it the biggest
thing is that the halek tree is clearly
inspired by the earth tree but the
difference is that nicolas haleg tree is
said to be accepting of all
even those the ode tree shunts mickler
himself was once embedded inside of the
halig tree and he watered it with his
very own blood since it was a mere
sapling tragically however he was ripped
out of this womb during the shattering
and his heilig tree ultimately failed to
grow into an old tree becoming a
misshapen husk instead
but that's the story for another day
there's also a ton of cut content to do
with mykola and he's one of the most
mysterious demigods who i'm sure we'll
learn about more later
but there is one more thing that i want
to mention before i go it's kind of one
theory i had during the making of this
video
so mykola and millennia each have their
own butterflies
millennials is the aeonian butterfly
which inhabit the swamp of aeonia and a
rumor to come from the wings of the rot
goddess herself
and i think it's fair to say that
michela's butterfly is the nascent
butterfly which appears as if it's just
emerged from its cocoon for its entire
life
this is a reference to mikala's eternal
youth and his cocoon in the heilig tree
but there is of course a third butterfly
right there's the smoldering butterfly
it's said to be an eternally burning
butterfly that serves as kindling
now bear with me but it's my theory that
this butterfly is a reference to melano
who the blade of calling calls the
kindling maiden and the one who walks
alongside flame this might suggest that
melano is a sibling to melania and
mikala again that's just a theory but
what i really want to talk about here is
that at the very least melania is almost
certainly the daughter of america we
learned this a long time ago from
looking at her name in the game's files
and we can further infer it from her
dialogue as she has a few lines that
refer to mothers and one that says that
she was born inside the erd tree so her
being the daughter of america is also
just a theory but this one is much more
concrete than the butterfly one although
the reason i like the butterfly theory
is that it gives us a hint as to who
melina's parents might have been her
parents would have been ratigan and
america which is to say america herself
alone i guess because radigan is america
honestly melania as a character has only
become more mysterious since the game
was released and i'm really only
scratching the surface with this theory
but speaking of times before eldon ring
was released back then a long time ago i
commissioned this piece from a renowned
artist named marco and now i'm so
excited to reveal it for the first time
this storybook scene is heavily inspired
by the early looks we had at eldon ring
with a redhead protagonist spirit
companions a mount that looks like yakul
and a bit like torrent and a few other
hidden details in the piece
this piece and all of my other prints
are now available over at spring where
you can actually buy them fully framed
and ready to hang they actually ship
with a beautiful frame the frame itself
is a nice black satin finish and you can
even opt for a white border around the
print which i think looks really classy
in certain cases i think these posters
are a cool way to support the channel
and artists and for you to actually get
something in return that will make your
room look better so check out my prints
if you're interested but this is the end
and thank you for watching i'll see you
next time